hope you guys spent the weekend
preparing your bodies because this week
we're getting overwatch it's a new week
and it's time for new releases Blizzard
Grace's us with an FPS for the ages with
overwatch this is squad based combat
with two opposing team six players
fitting within specific roles like
offense for tank and healer you'll see a
lot of similarities to much beloved tf2
including game modes like a salt Ness
court you'll fall in love with the
characters for both their unique play
styles and they're interesting
backgrounds each player has their own
depth of gameplay you'll have to learn
and master except for Reaper you just
hit Q with that guy either way you start
taking out the trash on the 24th also
this week you get to hang out leonardo
Donatello Michelangelo and Raphael
because Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
mutants in Manhattan is coming out this
is an action hack and slash where each
turtle has their own ability and power
as well as different fighting style and
ultimate ability for example Leonardo
can slow down time and Michelangelo can
fittingly cheerlead which reinstates the
cooldowns of all the other turtles
abilities you can shift between turtles
at will in the single-player campaign if
you get down you go back into the sewers
and have to finish a minigame of eating
pizza to regain your health bar yeah
it's that silly most importantly the
game supports four player online
cooperative multiplayer so you and your
three bros can join up for some co-op
fun online cowabunga on the 24th turn
based RTS fans get total war warhammer
this week tense title in the Total War
series but unlike its predecessors which
feature historical settings or hammer
introduces fantasy setting which is
really nice word for we made this [ __ ]
up you're getting monsters warriors and
heroes all falling within four playable
factions at launch which are as follows
Empire the greenskins the dwarfs and the
vampire counts each faction will have
access to their own unique traits for
example the green-skinned faction
features units churches trolls Giants
and Iraq nuraghe spiders you can enjoy
way more animations in this total war
war hammer to clarify you get 30 types
of different skeletons and body types as
opposed to only five or six in the
previous games as
well is flying units you've been
recruited into a fake war and we're
counting on you send out those troops on
the 24th omnibus is the next to last gen
physics game about the most powerful bus
in the universe that can't change its
speed there's no way to slow the bus
down it always has to maintain that
speed it's like that movie about speed I
think it was called the bus that
couldn't slow down omnibus drivers get
to choose between bizarre mission modes
thrilling trick modes and local versus
multiplayer modes for up to four players
to achieve goals set high scores and ask
themselves what decisions in their lives
brought them to this point call yourself
the bus driver and take your friends to
school on the 26th finally I would be a
Miss not to mention my favorite vertical
indie shooter down well is coming to ps4
this week it's so good this game is hot
[ __ ] I can't talk enough about how much
I love it bounce on jerks heads combo
chain get health money and gun upgrades
to kill more jerks and get further down
the well before long you'll get good and
you'll visit the catacombs under water
and limbo forever falling in search of
glory and bullets get this game so
that's all I have for you this week I
wasn't kidding about down well it's the
best game get it remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they change i'll see you guys
an overwatch